hey YouTube we'll get to tonight's game
of Thrones themed episode in a second
along with yl and Omar is evil I wanted
to take a few seconds just to let you
know that for the first time this
channel in its videos organic traffic
through YouTube have been drastically
reduced it's more than the monetization
but right now a direct step in
eliminating our ability to reach you the
viewer at all my half-asian where Bill
Richmond has reached out to official
contacts we'll keep you updated but in
the interim it's never been more
important for you to support the show by
joining my club at La Toya's credit com
/ mug club and watching over there
please consider it if you haven't
already it's the only way this continues
enjoy the show
lahter with crowder studios protected
exclusively by walter and hopper
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
crowd huh miss what jetski who got your
account back up it was probably that
half-asian lawyer of yours he's always
good at fighting copyright strikes what
you're probably talking that is this
what you want Steven to point a crossbow
at your precious Susan Wojcicki while
she sits on a toilet I'm just surprised
it's not a Walther it would be both
historically and creatively inaccurate
you've always wanted me off youtube
haven't you yes but you refuse to let it
go I respect that even admire it you
fight for what's yours
I'd never permanently delete your
channels that would you fear you're far
too much fun to permanently take up you
and your temper tantrums every time we
ban your live stream folks and what I
found them in pieces shattered Oh your
gifts for those Mudd Club fool tried to
glue them back together with my own hair
just stupid cops say that word again
what you'll kill the only meal ticket
you have you hit me with false copyright
violations when you knew I hadn't
violated any rules Wow hold up let me
finish we can talk this over in my
office I can't go back there
the mugs are what are you afraid of a
few broken cups no you'll never hit 4
million subscribers I will hit 4 million
I was always going to at 4 million I
[Music]
just
[Music]
[Music]
I have no idea if Jon Snow does this and
the Game of Thrones does he flap the Jon
Snow I don't know Game of Thrones seemed
episode because my my crew hates me we
have different order here Jew Morgan Jr
what's one of the day 100 days [ __ ]
mark thank you Mark Ryan via a mark on
my bosom wishing you were here probably
wishing you were him right now and we
have McGuinness on the show today by the
way really about the dead McInnis
quarterblack show me hood best I drink I
know look he's a [ __ ] and we have the
hodgetwins hodge twins tour come here
has the unsullied would you know your
next tour dates yeah coming up in ohio
somewhere oh hi oh you don't you guys
don't watch Game of Thrones huh is this
what this is yeah you know what go to a
gay bar look up the unsullied after the
show and I'm sure I'll receive a letter
later yep today julian assange hero or
villain mom while we're at it killin
omar who we'll be talking about villain
villain or villain will get to Assange
in omar in a second year but first
attorney general bill Barse he said that
he was going to release the the molar
report full report within a week has
comes from Real Clear Politics this
process is going very well and within a
week I will be in a position to release
the report to the public that's good
Stelter has succumbed to a stress
induced coma yeah so oh Jesus so we're
told he's in stable condition and
surrounded by people who love Him oh
that sucks took a little time I know
you're thinking by the way we initially
were also more excited thinking that it
was Attorney General Bill burr okay I'm
not saying the president didn't do some
[ __ ] horrendous
alright okay I'm not saying that but on
the other side of the coin can we admit
that not every false rumor just [ __ ]
fell from the sky
okay I mean you guys spread the rumors
the pissing prostitutes brutal right
well BuzzFeed said it and then CNN said
it and oh [ __ ] off you guys are lying to
yourself right
I really wouldn't know I think
government would have been more
interesting that's if they are she
definitely have comedians testified
before Congress more often we should
yeah it would be a lot more fun to watch
Italy sometimes they do like Ted Leo
Julian Assange he was arrested at an
Ecuador that you know the Ecuadorian
Embassy in London everybody knows I know
I just have to say even though they had
an embassy there until he made the move
what are you laughing I don't know what
they're laughing about yet but they have
some cider in their mugs and over there
and anything above 2% just messes them
up basically michelob ultra or die for
them officers made the move after
Ecuador but through his asylum invited
authorities in the embassy sighting the
Australians the and recited his bad
behavior oh and the biggest complaints
was his internet usage not cleaning up
after his cat in his girlfriend's
incessant lobbying for funding for
barbed wire - so that seemed that's not
how the embassy works they don't fund
anything certainly not productions
Pamela Anderson by the way this is one
thing Bob made me think about this
you see barbed wire have you see did you
guys see barbed wire when you were kid
remember all the posters though for
Pamela Anderson never what why why did
it become considered sexism to be
sexually attracted to women like we
didn't put the breasts on the poster
I understand as a sex object I get it
but being sexually attracted to women
dude this is a question for the female
audience out there do you find it
offensive if a guy finds a woman sexy we
only hear that at a time that's sexism
its sexism to be physically attracted to
a sexually attractive woman it doesn't
mean that we think that's your only
quality to offer it that's nice
we don't marry you just because of how
you look it's just the window dressing
it's the curb appeal well yeah and
that's what I mean if I was wearing this
wonderful
busting outfit out in public as a female
I what would I be asking you to do not
it'll get me but thank god they're
unsullied because you'd have problems
alright
[Applause]
I nominate PewDiePie Donald Trump and
Will Smith
[Applause]
so Michael avenatti wasn't tight it this
is a very white program yeah I get it
Hodgman what is what like what do we
bring some cold he was 36 charges of tax
dodging perjury and theft from clients
comes from the LA Times grand jury
alleges that avenatti stole millions for
five clients use a tangled web of shell
companies and bank accounts to cover it
up so third there you go
36 count so last the probe into avenatti
has come to an end as we transition to a
probe into avenatti if you're gonna be a
slimy criminal do me a favor avoid the
spotlight if every like gangster movie
that's ever been made has taught us
anything is that if you're gonna break
the law and be that guy do it behind the
scenes where nobody notices see it and
talk to stuff all went silent in unison
on my possible remember the more fun you
have the more fun
they'll have let's just make sure we
hate doing this show international news
because we're international here after
all I was raised in Montreal Chinese
company they've now created an automatic
this is this is a real story I'm sorry
pg-13 warning automatic sperm extractor
to help clinics collect one seed from
donors who are reluctant to service
themselves yeah yeah because that's
that's how you'll solve your birthrate
problem China you can actually get those
in the stove yeah there's that in the
store it's a kiosk if they have because
that's out that's how China's gonna
solve their problems by being raped by
robots Oh reports month later actually
emerging that these receptacles have
customizable dirty digital dirty talk
options yes yeah
boy not a dotter no oh yeah listen I'm
around when you have a one-child policy
it is important that it's a boy oh my
gosh can you imagine walking up and
standing next to being the guy but it
extracts it sorry it just was going in
it out of its just like come on who's
the guy Brian just because he's no he's
smart but you know not funny and so then
he tries to send it the other way it's
not fair it's not right then your
soon-to-be marriage is a sham
this is China nutshell dragging it right
now they work 20 hours a day
they control 1/5 of the world's GDP but
too lazy to masturbate that is the
Chinese gotta get a piece more high on
SATs than both hodgetwins combined you
try it can't be one-size-fits-all though
either right I mean they gotta have like
different attachments let's not get into
the stereotypes here because I'm not
comfortable with it
hodgetwins you guys agrees attachment
right oh definitely they are the
unsalted would be here the art claims
the TGI Fridays potato skins contain no
actual potato skins this comes from
Reuters Danny you know it's a slow news
when they're not editing flotillas and
trying to vilify Israel they're talking
about TGI Fridays potato skins the claim
is a company misleads consumers by
selling potato skins snacks that contain
potato flakes potato starch but no skins
is actually part of a giant class-action
lawsuit also claims it Snickers don't
really satisfy Funyuns don't contain any
fun and that Alexandria Acacio Cortez
isn't really black
there's a lot wrong with that the
congresswoman's black cell caused quite
a stir online this week or every well I
need everyone to be quiet because if we
actually I think you're here to address
the controversy right now is
representative Alexandria Acacio Cortez
mr. Cortez thanks for being back on the
show this is what a congresswoman sounds
like okay what's what's happening right
now what you talking about Steven
but congresswoman we wanted to talk with
you about the fallout from your recent
appearance at the Al Sharpton event oh
my gosh I know Steven it was dynomite
all right okay some say that you may
have been pandering to the largely
african-american crowd I've heard the
criticism from the haters and let me
just say desam okay all right it seems
like seems like you might come blowing
it right now again panders fool or
should I say Manders no it's not let's
try and stay on topic here listen this
is this is what happened with Hillary
Clinton before then Joe Biden and some
might argue the DNC has a long history
of trying to play up to different
minority okay what what are you talking
about what's what's happening man just
drop that clown you see it at home
no sorry that was on the peripheral
there I'm very lost at this point anyway
Steven code-switching is a very common
rhetorical tool okay and community
activism by communicating in the
vernacular the audience you're looking
to motivate it helps to connect with
them in a deeper level and I believe you
and I both know exactly what that means
and what's that fool you straight up
acting like oh no no no no congresswoman
you can't does everybody know that's
enough of that you guys come back in and
change the save this hearsay but let's
get rid of her there you go Cortez in
her voice there yeah that was horrible
what she did talking to those black
people like black people you get him
girl okay
right she sees black people is like sir
put in servants like what's his name
Morgan Freeman of driving these days
miss days I'm gonna make me some water
he's gonna make himself wash yeah
whenever we had to go to the bathroom a
movie I loved that movie we go into the
stove the Piggly Wiggly look nobody
there called her on it either exactly
what you heard you get home girl right
and they prayed the other was like come
on come on and she just kept going
further and further into it and nobody
said anything why the only people that
was upset was white people who were
there no after like old social meeting
nobody blacks didn't say anything I mean
but history would it pitched like
legitimately pissed you guys off Yeah
right yeah it was it just like because
it's pain because you know your message
should be the same full regardless of
the group you're talking to right yeah
change the voice and I was like and her
rhythm is because you know my father
Darren books the show yeah everyone else
was afraid to but how most guests
surprised wouldn't appear in the show so
he often hangs out and takes you guys to
lunch does he ever slip into the black
guy voice with you guys because every
now and then he does that with black
people
[Laughter]
we call them places too healthy he'll
panic yeah but it's why did you can get
gluten-free you have to be the whitest
person in the world to eat right and
freak hey by the way this week's trivia
contest winner is Sofia Lazarus at some
wonder scoreless who correctly answered
that Ben Shapiro was a conservative I
made uncomfortable by not wearing pants
before we move on to everything wrong
with Elon Omar which I should have
robably mentioned in the outset yes
because I think it's it's it's necessary
to get into Illinois more before that
yeah obviously Game of Thrones this
Sunday apparently I'm supposed to do a
review of the show but we may be on the
road doing a change my mind instead yeah
everyone you're watching Game of Thrones
you just watch I don't get it I've seen
everything I don't like to show no six I
don't like this show no I don't like to
show it all my not I think it's terrible
writing no I mean tell me why you don't
like the show everything
the show is crappy everything about the
show scrappy seems a parody we were
picking the scene to parody we literally
couldn't find a single scene to pair
because nothing was iconic enough
there's it's that dull
there's no iconic dialogue is having
some getting their head back there's no
iconic subscribe a ttle of the bastards
red wedding and the one where the White
Walkers finally show up and there at the
coast
those were cool and the rest I used to
think I really want to like the show Wow
10 I really want to like the show tens
of millions of people maybe even more
than that disagree with you transformers
5 you know what that's true I got a joke
in my show oh I can't give it away if
you want to see the joke go to a tour
date which is yet to be announced
because it had a cider so outside
somewhere we think somewhere in Ohio
this month well look no I I think the
show I like pieces or I like shows that
are in this kind of rough time piece
right I know it's not it's fictional but
it kind of portrays a time I enjoyed
that I think the writing is actually
much better than you give it credit for
I don't like the amount of second it has
I don't like the amount of violence I
like no it's not has nothing to do with
the sexual violence you didn't every
single episode every single episode eNOS
okay we were just talking about this one
the the angry short lesbian oh she joins
these fashion assassins they don't have
faces what are they called the faceless
men they're called the faceless man you
can't really have no multiple there's a
faceless men great writing George Martin
it was it's obviously pretty good
writing I think you're just being I
think it gets a free pass along with
films like Lord of the Rings no but
because it's medieval and people who
play Dungeons and Dragons and want to
fantasize about life that they don't
live like to feel as though this is cool
I mean I'm sitting there and I'm
watching Denarius get chubbier as each
season goes by getting on dragons it's
just okay hold on a second she got it
like does she got raped by awesome man
and now she's travelling with dragons
and the [ __ ] is an alcoholic and the
guy was I just ended this whole arm you
know Plateau
like the inner cities yeah
you know nothing steven crowder all
right six on
that's how weak the writing is the game
of Thrones the throw out of reference
and it's that on entertaining now it's
because you're not so much it was a
given for use to get into it you'll get
this peach draw to give us on drugs
right in this entire room could have
heard a rat piss on cotton somebody
laughed alright so some context L on
Omar is the worst the absolute worst is
a congresswoman Minnesota not to be
confused with the other oddly named
terrorist supporter Rasheed until a
representative from Mission a lot of
people get that wrong your bornus I want
to make sure that people understand that
she's you guys are familiar with her
right yeah they meaning these two women
but while we're talking about not not
sleep who are we talking about yo mark I
wanted to make sure there was a pop quiz
she's a freshman congresswoman hasn't
really accomplished a whole lot but you
likely already know her name why because
the media has been promoting this woman
non-stop she's been on the cover of Time
Newsweek Rolling Stone New York magazine
so she went on Colbert last night were
they discussed discuss quite a bit but
they mainly discuss to fall out some of
her recently as she puts it misconstrued
we'll get to that clip in a second Pro
terrorist anti-semitic comments
specifically the ones about 900 hear her
say it
but you will have people get come after
minorities for things that they say I
mean like they might have insinuated
actually said people like the the folks
on Fox and Friends that actually say
those words not about insinuation what
people make it their career to go after
Fox and Friends if there's an entire
site Media Matters
that just it is just a list a laundry
list of Fox and Friends got this wrong
this is what they ate for lunch at the
Fox at the news for cafeteria this is
one thing that was like that you never
hear it about people on the right no you
hear it all the time by the way this is
what you actually said here was founded
after 9/11 because they recognize that
some people did something Wow and that
all of us were starting to lose access
our civil liberties something
understatement I've ever heard she also
by the way referred to the pulse night
clip shooting as a simple
misunderstanding Pearl Harbor as a
whoopsie-daisy into the 93 World Trade
Center bombing was nothing more than
college hazing with a couple of kids and
black cats so that's not all that's
wrong with her let me give you just a
few more reasons as to why she's awful
here's one she's anti-science okay you
hear just about the right all the time
in February the United States
powerlifting Association they banned
male to female transgender from
complaining as women and it's so funny I
have this one a story site as though
they need to cite this citing men's
biological advantages here's gonna laugh
that's like power lifting they had to
cite men's biological advantages it's
almost like it's self-explanatory no she
sent an angry letter okay demanding the
Minnesota Attorney General investigate
the powerlifting organization what
stating what the myth the myth that
trans women have a quote direct
competitive advantage is not supported
by medical science in a continues to
stoke fear and violence against one of
the most at-risk communities in the
world no advantage someone wants to have
a word with you look up
[Music]
so live is a man until he was I think 32
and then decided to beat the hell out of
women right
by the way heard her quote most at-risk
people yeah in the Islamic countries
around the world they are the most
at-risk people there's not a lot of
people that look like being witch boobs
in a hairy chest in Islamic countries
second only to the at-risk people who
the men beat the hell out of it
oh you tell me I found Fox 10 yeah yeah
no Omar didn't do that we have a lot a
lot of faults we can find with her but I
don't want to but this doesn't no more
have enough battles to fight she has to
pick up the trans the transgender in a
second this is what's so amazing to me
like your United States representative
yeah and you decide that this is going
to be the fight you're going to pick
with the Minnesota powerlifting
Association and saying there's no direct
competitive advantage it's not supported
by medical science and also this is one
thing cuz it's not supported by medical
science you have to accept it wholesale
right but they'll and then they use the
flip side with if you don't accept the
climate change science meaning that the
Kyoto Protocol or the Paris Accord will
actually fix China's emission standards
if you don't buy that all Sun your anti
science but then they say it's Stokes
fear and violence against one of the
most so here's what that means if you
say hold on a second men who become
women actually do have some biological
advantages yeah they are going to accuse
you of committing hate crime but raise
crime right hate speech because you are
driving hatred toward the most at-risk
community really actually all I'm doing
is saying that when you're a guy you're
a little stronger than when you're a
girl bone-density fast twitch muscle
fibers reaction time we're gonna do a
whole episode on that because now
there's been so many Trianon they'll
just just beaten the hell out of four
female athletes in the world is saying
anybody who's a man that wants to
compete as a woman now we're gonna break
all of your records you're never gonna
win another medal again as long as you
wait I hate to see what the Debian
beigel know there's one person that can
dunk they'll be God okay look so much
we believe Rico's baby methinks Nike
regrets doing that retirement Jersey for
Dwayne Wade so early just give him the
weaves there none the wiser now next
reason will probably end up on the
florida WNBA games that are on a spirit
airline center aisle yes and by the way
you donate that she's hates Jews okay
Omar says she actually no because that
Tess Emmet can technically include
Arabic and I understand people who say
they use it as cover but you know let's
just say she hates Jewish people she
says the Jews have hypnotized the world
the u.s. is controlled by a cabal of
wealthy Jews Oh classic anti-jewish
tropes and I know you're going to hear
the left say well what about King okay
score one for you all right the one put
that up in this court here's the thing
there's a difference between I think
that's miss speaking saying something
stupid or even saying something maybe
once that could be a little earnestly
racist or prejudice coming from a blind
spot here's one think - I do it's not
just about Miss speaking I think
everyone black or white has probably
said something that if you look back say
you know what that was a little bit
racist and it came from ignorance and
doesn't mean hatred I don't think we
should hang people for even that no I
definitely read I've definitely done
that before I said something one time
that was kind of offensive to a person
that I was with and I was like ah crap
right after it I look that's why I have
a wig on they did some a number on my
head this happens on both sides right
when put on the public eye but here's
with Omar she knows exactly what she's
saying she repeatedly doubles down on it
it's not a dog whistle well you're that
term all the time dog no she knows
exactly what she's saying in the context
in which you say it's not a misspeak
it's a worldview
a worldly that comes directly from where
where anyone guess what what the founder
of the feast Mohammed send your
paintings a test route well look it
seems like no matter what Jews and
Christians are always fair game Jews
have been the most persecuted people in
the history of mankind right and you
have somebody and really no one else
using Christians if you say anything
about any other group you're immediately
somebody who's either some hate speech
was like she said you're picking on the
most
at risk group of people in the world
right in the 1930s in the United States
we had tons of people that not
anti-semitism hated Jews that's a better
way to say it right in 1939 there was
actually a poll that said only 39% of
Americans thought that Jews should be
treated like the rest of the people in
the country
yeah the year before that only 60
percent are actually sixty percent
thought that Jews were basically bad
people they were scheming they were
connivers and that they controlled the
money supply 60% that's why when
something like this happens would what
she says with about the juice we you
have to stand up and say no we're not
gonna go back to the place that we were
it's too easy I think she you know she
saw all the progress the Jewish people
had made and then she saw the Weinstein
story as her opening three decades of
Jewish faith I mean politics people are
gonna turn a blind eye and say oh it's
okay to pick on Jews it's okay to just
say that you guys know Farrakhan you
know I'm talking about that was my dad I
guess he's been on his best behavior
with you if you doubt any of this by the
way what we're just talking about Jews
because I get I know they're going to be
a couple of people out there in the
comments-section like oh I knew you were
working for Benjamin Netanyahu she's
actually pro terrace power that though
hit the notification bail because
subscriptions don't mean a whole lot
they mean less than ever on on YouTube
organic creatures gone down dramatically
we don't know what's going on right now
it's crazy so you need to join up a lot
of thunder calm slash mug Club subscribe
on iTunes give us a rating there okay
here's an X reason she's actually Pro
terrorist and I don't mean kind of sort
of she's literally proactively Pro
terrorist okay she begged for she begged
for compassion and Isis sentencing voted
in support of life insurance payouts for
terrorists I was after San Bernardino
where she wanted to make sure they they
still got what they get I get smile area
but few people vote the vote was 127 to
2
yes and she was one of G with one or two
there was an amendment on it that he
didn't like but Greg the rest of the
bill is yeah it was two who voted
against in the first guy said like hold
on a second I think it's gonna be
misconstrued they clarified it yet okay
I was wrong about that and she's still
sitting it no why because Jews so good
wait a minute she uh terrorists can go
blow himself up he leans
well hundreds that maybe thousands of
people eat get paid in life insurance
yes pretty much well you can put
yourself in a situation San Bernardino
on today's yeah they Pat they were
trying to pass a law that would ban that
that would put certain limits that it
was a terrorist action and there was no
life insurance policy for the insurance
company to have to worry about right and
she said no you can't do that if he goes
and shoots 27 people and then gets shot
by the cops he died you have to pay out
what that's what she was saying yeah I
remember when I said my life is positive
if I killed myself within two years I
wouldn't get the money well I wouldn't
get my family we get it no you still
wouldn't get it if you killed yourself
yeah a terrorist action and the cops
took you out you're a seer a suggest I'm
not misusing literally here's a clip she
laughed literally about Hezbollah al
Qaeda and she said as we already said
we'll run the clip again because think
it's important to 9/11 was just
something some people did yes in
totality the the professor said okay
that he sort of like his shoulders went
up and you know after 9/11 because they
recognize that some people did something
and that all of us were starting to lose
access to our civil liberties she also
just sounds crazy she did some she
sounds like the Andy Kaufman character
from taxi yeah they blow up a bunch of
people on a bus
the create care to protect their care is
a designated terrorist organization most
notably by the way by the UAE ventured
servitude did they have experience with
it by the way just just a clarification
care was started in 1994 so what did she
say she said after 9/11 oh yeah so you
know quite a few years was ended we
don't have enough time to go through all
but look into care look into their ties
to Hamas funneling funneling lie ahead a
lot look into their fake hate crimes
that they've perpetrated all these
hoaxes on the American people and if you
still aren't convinced remember this is
the organization that brought you clock
boy so that should be they helped Clark
boy try to sue Ben Shapiro and lost
money to Hezbollah all right and here's
the first reason why I think she's
absolutely awful and this might surprise
a lot of you so this next one it's it's
a little bit difficult for me to set up
not I don't know exactly how to frame it
she she married her brother now when I
see actually married her brother's rip
it off like a bandage
yes just say it people she began her
political it did you really know it yeah
I really do it yeah gets worse though
so she when she began local news outlets
right they they uncovered early on in
her political career documents
suggesting she might have married her
brother presumably to commit immigration
fraud I think to already has some
headlines here well yeah well yes no I
say I say suggesting don't do it it's
only gonna make me mad at him on a roll
here
I say suggesting she married her brother
because it started with sources which
uncovered her ex-husband's name on her
marriage and divorce records okay and
they happen to be exactly the same as
her brother Ahmed and nurse said Elmi I
might not be pronouncing that correctly
I don't care because America now some
people may say that's just like John
Smith over there that's why I say it
could be suggesting we don't know I
don't know there's like Silva Brazil is
like this but now I'm gonna give you
that one but if we continue on down the
research trail school records also
confirm that the man she married was
living in her father's house in high
school well social media posts show the
guy
that she claims with her ex-husband now
calls her children his nieces she refers
to them as their uncle awkward
coincidence who's your favorite uncle I
mean that's she's the cool aunt and
their mother now I consider it beyond
the realm of suggestion however all of
this I encourage you to research should
go we hit to hit the the sources that
are listed on the page here and for
people complaining why didn't you just
put in a description it would be too
long you can see the source is right
there on the screen just hit rewind hit
pause man I do consider it beyond the
realm of suggestion however when you
take into account that her brother's
high school enrollment records lists his
date of birth April 4th 1985 okay okay
anyone want to guess the birth date of
her ex-husband according to official
marriage documents and divorce
proceedings what is it to be true I
encourage you to look at the evidence
for yourself the story broke the guy
deleted all of his a media parents and
her response remember she is official
statement she denied it and she said a
difficult part of my personal history
that I did not consider although in the
context of political campaign she's at
the insinuations that he's my brother
that are absurd and offensive okay he is
your brother
how about any proof any proof just trot
out your non brother husband and shut
everybody up easy now
is it possible like because I have to in
the spirit of fairness yes is it
possible that she just married a man who
happened to have the exact same name as
her brother happen to have the exact
same birthday does her brother happen to
live in the exact same house as both her
and her brother and it not be her
brother if I had an eight ball and say
you're [ __ ] it is unbelievable that
it's worse than banging the goats which
by the way we don't know what her
brothers up to today he deleted his
social media yeah I wonder what both of
those could be included in this story
but we have no idea and it's a crime if
she if she used it for for immigration
purposes it
absolutely a crime and nobody's
concerned with that as in with you know
children with webbed toes yes this is
like Arkansas sorry do that here
IOC press the the Twitter account a s he
presses really funny sometimes they post
something I didn't say this that's why I
have to say that said it's it's really
interesting that she can post a picture
of her husband on national siblings day
[Laughter]
this is what bothers me most about about
Omar okay now I'm not doing the judge
mean things saying you wear a a jab does
that mean you follow Sharia law do you
hate America
no no but here's the thing if you do if
you look at the totality of the policies
that she supports if you look at the
organization she supports these
organizations by and large support
countries that implement Sharia law or
they've outright talked about having
area law Sharia Courts Sharia law is one
hundred-percent irreconcilable with the
Constitution okay and by the way all of
these problems that we're bringing up
brothers aiding the Jews being Pro
terrorism they're all congruent with
Muhammad's teachings yeah that's the
issue what really bothers me though I
think most about Ellen Alma is how much
this show Kate it's actually a blessing
I guess how much it showcases the left
hypocrisy let me paint for you okay let
me let me pay for you just to try and
drive the point home here if I could for
a moment alright put on your imagination
cap a United States congressman okay
came from the hills of West Virginia who
just hit Kahoot just hates how all them
Jews read everything the Jews control
all the banks and she's controlling
cameras just any bangs his sister he'd
be mocked and booted before Colbert's
opening monologue he is she just happens
to be brown a Muslim there you go we
have Gavin McCourt what are you gonna
say room I like to go from West Virginia
but hodgetwins toward document Gavin
McInnes coming right yes
[Music]
your mind let us begin our quest to find
no sound
[Music]
a wall now this frankly is a wall 700
feet tall of solid ice okay
frankly those seven Kingdom caravans
aren't breaking the drugs and rapes over
here that's right winner baby coming
okay but this Night Watch is gonna grab
it by the pig Walker and oh oh no no
this is a good sir looks like the
Mexicans brought some of the Giants with
the giant sir if I put to Olli you could
save the Seven Kingdoms by joy they get
a ladder with credit.com slash bug Club
okay frankly it's $99 annually but only
60 night for students veterans active
military that's what that's such a great
deal that's what they tell me I've given
you such a great deal I don't see it
that's what they tell me latter what
credit a cop slash ball club said two
kingdoms
last week we introduced you to the
Athene tunic cool area known by its
common name the burrowing or ground our
it lives in parts of North and South
America investing your grasslands
deserts and increasingly your
neighborhoods rather than take to the
skies like other glorious birds of prey
he chooses to live in the dirt like a
subterranean scumbag of course many
argue it's not our place to question
God's creations but the Lord has no
place here as the ground owl is clearly
the devil's work
either that or the Lord has made a
terrible mistake
join Mudd Club at louder with Crider
calm / Mudd Club for access to the full
daily show the entire blazed catalogue a
wonderful hand etched mug but more
importantly you'll support the
livelihood of this program but most
importantly join Mudd Club to help us
kill all the ground hours today louder
with prouder shock tom is now selling
baseball team in red blue and ash get
yours at ladder with quite a shop calm
today
[Music]
I'm not entirely sure it's a cultural
appropriation for Pogo to do that I'm
not sure I don't know I don't know what
what what constitutes cultural
appropriation just taking a beat if
you're sampling I have no idea maybe our
next guest can answer the question for
us you know um you love him it's been a
while hasn't been that long it's been
about a month month and a half since
he's been on the program you can go to
defend Gavin calm as well as a no hate
calm with Miles McGuinness but right now
on today we have Gavin McInnes how are
you sir I'm good you know it's a trip
when I was told a you want to be on
crowded show I go I can't be on crowded
show I'm watching crowded show right now
and then they go we'll just turn on the
camera and then you can be on the show
that you were just watching and I'm like
well and I know now I am watching it as
well which is wildly uncomfortable so
you're watching me watching you uh-huh
there is nothing we can do watching me
watching you okay all right I see where
this is going except not really seems to
me like you have some new technology new
TriCaster technology that you're just
futzing around with over there yeah
confused ology more like what's going on
with your ensemble this is one of the
characters from a game of Thrones
apparently I've seen every episode and
I'm very ashamed if you were a game of
Thrones character Gavin who would you be
I'd probably be the [ __ ] because I'm
short I thought you were being cats
because in the new cat's musical they're
making it to scale so buildings are
gonna be super huge and you know the
door will be gigantic and stuff like it
is for cats that's that sounds wildly
expensive and sounds like it could be a
worse disaster than spider-man on
Broadway remember that then it was
opening weekend and the guy just fell
and broke his back what could about
people kept dying yeah they want to make
it just like spider-man so they sent
actors flying over the audience and
people kept getting broken legs and
spina bifida and some chick got AIDS
when a guy cut himself and eventually
they had to shut it down that sounds
like spider-man meets rent Gavin what is
going on or cats I don't know I assumed
there are dirty
around the green room somewhere and
either one of those productions what can
you give us any status update on what's
going on with your lawsuit against the
Southern Poverty Law Center
it's amazing going through all these
court documents and reading all your
jokes out of context like they didn't
include my introduction to naked fart
yoga yoga on no hate calm they didn't
include how to fight a baby or my
autobiography how to piss in public but
they have all this really serious jargon
like and then he called Asians rice
balls and I'm reading it going is it
occur to you that that person was
kidding when they said rice balls let's
try this your honor
can you tell me of another human on
earth in 2019 or any surrounding year
who would use that in a seriously these
damn rice balls are coming in here
taking our job it's not used in that
context it was obviously a joke it may
be if there were an uncle who were
racist but didn't know how to use
pointed racist language we called them
rice balls and the people of color we
called them colored people maybe you
know I could see it an Asian immigrant
who decided that he was just going to
become a anti-asian racist and he was
like we come here I don't I don't want
me to come here I'm so mad at all rice
balls yeah rice ball rice ball rice ball
you know no no.you rice ball no speak
for me rice ball creation okay
shut it all right yeah pretty much
that's so so do you have any jokes that
you've made that worry you most you
welcome the day in court where you can
talk about these things in front of a
judge or do you go oh yeah that one out
of context could be could be troubling
no III think I heard was it Zach
Galifianakis this one you may have to
beep this but um Zach Galifianakis said
I didn't know was a derogatory term for
I don't know if this is a Zach
Galifianakis by the way but I came over
we said this joke but they go I didn't
know it was a derogatory term for Asians
and I was skiing and I was like hey do
you want to hit the slopes and these two
chicks got
super madam yeah that's a that's very
much like a joke that Sarah Silverman
used to make until she slammed the doors
behind her and said now you can't use
the word gay hey let me a couple of
things since you were last on what's it
been like for you now that we know
there's no Russia collusion and then I
wanted to get into the the candice owens
controversy from yesterday because i'm
sure you have some opinions that's juicy
stuff
well the russian collusion thing has not
wavered have you noticed this right
Stephen Colbert says it's time to get
our hopes back again I hope back up
again Rachel Maddow goes I hope you
enjoyed your victory lap meaning now
that we are going at the ACLU is
threatened to sue to get a hundred
percent of the report which doesn't
exist in law we can't be outing
witnesses you have a there's no such
thing as a zero percent redacted report
but that's what they've demanded or
they're gonna sue right so I think the
left it's sort of like these doomsday
cults where they go the world's gonna
end on August 19th and then on August
20th to go wow you guys must be bombed
out and they go no now there's more
members we have worth more devoted to
the gods yeah like well no more obsessed
Russia than ever now we're really
invested in our leader being a foreign
agent that will be a big big W for us no
I think I think that's a good point in
the redactions yeah I think a lot of
people understand how this works and
it's always ironic to me I've been
watching The West Wing lately again a
Netflix and of course this is where you
always see the altruistic journalists
that only exist in programs like this
the left is always obsessed like
BuzzFeed like most of the the original
Russia stories right the trumps
trumpeting uh watching prostitutes
pissing on furniture I don't remember
this tribe you can come here but they
always say well it's very important that
I protect my sources release the full
report all redacted means is that the
copy you're seeing isn't a hundred
percent the same as the first trap and
you know if they release the full report
that missing sentence that missing one
line that missing tiny word is going to
be where all the collusion is hiding
right they are so and it's late to the
Candice Owens thing because it's about
this myopic obsession with your stupid
theory so your stupid theory is that
there's Nazis everywhere
on every corner behind every corner and
the trumped work with Russia and Trump's
a white supremacist and that's my theory
and I don't want to hear anything else
and you go where's your proof well
Candace Owens said Hitler II Hitler
wanted to make Germany great so Hitler
was great is that what you're saying
why right yeah no that's not what she
said it all also leaves out a big piece
of the pie that the Russians were not
necessarily huge fans of the Nazis quite
a few people lost their lives in that
little scuffle going on there no it is
if there's going to be anything redacted
you know this is what it's not see at
the left this is lost in them it's like
listen you are the people who talk about
all right trolls doxxing we have to
redact some information to protect the
privacy of people because we're
concerned remember again you're the ones
who wanted to kill kids and Majah hats
right so I think it's a reasonable
concern as with all legal documents in
the history of law that's how it works
folks that's it now as it has this been
the case with your ongoing a suit with
us PLC and where can people go to find
more updates on this defend Gavin com
has all the updates where they had a
motion to dismiss tons of other people
are getting involved we've got on
defendant calm we have well over 6,000
different people contributing to this
case and I think that is scarier to the
SPLC than the money because money is
just rich guys writing checks but when
there's that many people involved and
I've been told from insiders that this
house of cards is crumbling I think
they're outraged that their net has
expanded so far so there are
hard-working people at the SPLC with our
nose to the grindstone and then they get
a complaint coming in what's this and
they read and go what the hell are we
doing here we're persecuting the Knights
of Columbus they're an extremist group
people are going to jail we're
infiltrating social media well why are
we talk about racism and sexism all time
Morris Dees can't keep his paws off me
every time I'm at my desk so richard
cohen goes he's the president he goes
don't worry don't worry don't worry
we're fixing everything gavin is the
worst guy in the world he's racist and
sexist bring me it rid of them and
Morris Dees you're right you're right
he is racist and sexist
his behavior is not part of our culture
it's not what we pride ourselves on so
he's gone
so they fire him and then people go well
you're kind of corrupt too I mean you
and the head illegal here you don't seem
to know what you're doing and they go
that's why we're quitting we're me and
Rhonda Brown seen the head illegal were
both quitting and we have a black woman
taking our place the black woman's gonna
take over now now are we cool thanks so
I think what you're saying is you just
need to hire a black female lawyer
preferably one who's transgender with
rickets
I identify as exactly that I don't know
how you knew I guess that you can sense
I just I figured you get all the trump
cards if you bring a disabled
transgender woman of color with rickets
in there some disease that should be
eradicated you know by by vaccines or
vitamin D they keep reiterating their
own racism and sexism too like they got
this woman in and there's SPLC employees
they have all these bloggers going this
seems like a great direction for the
SPLC and they just show a picture of her
face they don't say anything about her
policies anything about her experience
they just show her gender and her race
it's and they go you see we're really
doing a good job and it's a stark
contrast well dummies it's a stark
contrast to what happened with with
Candis Owens yesterday we talked about
this yesterday with the hodgetwins you
know I don't agree with necessarily
everything that she said and I think
anytime you draw any sort of a positive
comparison or analogy with Hitler it's
politically ill-advised but do we really
think for any second there that that
people sitting there on that committee
believed that she supports Hitler's
genocide against the Jews do you really
think anyone believes that you can say
she misspoke you can say maybe it was an
inarticulate comment you can say maybe
it was distasteful any look but do you
really think she supports the death of
six million Jews let's comb through the
entire continent from top to bottom and
ask every single individual about Hitler
and try to find one person who goes I
think you did a pretty good job I like
him I think it's a good guy
you could scour the whole continent with
whale's teeth find filament go through
you might find like four four
and they're not going to be articulate
and successful like Candace Owens
they're gonna be morbidly obese with
type 2 diabetes a strange sort of
festering corn on his foot and a tick or
they could be one of our fine
representatives from the great state of
Minnesota or or you're by the way no I
you know what leo let's give where I'm
it's everything's in Reverse all right
there we go give me a little bit they
know I'm going the wrong way now huh
this is this is going off the rails no
that actually did it for people
listening on audio you have to go but we
were shooting a video a a chain we were
shooting crap confronts in Texas and we
had a sign I had a sign on it said not a
Nazi because we had this teacher but
Professor Charles Charles Fermi's who
repeatedly referred to me as a Nazi and
as I was taping that you end up this
Muslim guy drove by and said what are
you bad-mouthing Hitler greatest guy
ever man and drove off so I think maybe
you might find more than you bargained
for if you peel back some curtains in
Dearborn well he did laugh his head off
though no he seemed pretty serious it
was more of a maniacal laugh and an you
know the sarcastic laugh it wasn't like
just kidding bro
it was more like Jews yes PLC is totally
devoted to finding homophobia sexism
racism any kind of super religious
dogmatism extremism and you show them
Islam and they go excuse me move move
anyway right that guy he called it a
party while playing beer pong wait no
not him his pug his pug it's enough get
out miss Omar just let's go for the pub
all right we have to get going here mr.
McGinnis it is defend Gavin calm and
anywhere else that you want to direct
people here as they can follow your
ongoing battle with the SPOC
another thing I'd love people to check
out is imdb.com it's got a huge list of
a millions of movies you can see the
cast of who was in the movie box office
there's also the parental guide if
you're not sure if your kids want to
watch it or not they got Animal House
there they just got a whole bunch of new
releases on there
and it's it's like rotten tomatoes but
not as fun yes it is a very valuable
resource and I appreciate you bringing
it to our attention
defend gavest bet defend Gatos defend
Gavin calm Gavin McInnes thanks for what
you know look I got a lab I finally
stopped being cheap no right we gotta go
this is enough that's enough I hide you
hide you
[Music]
join the club lateral CARICOM / MOCA
it's $99 annually
69 for students and veterans in active
military do it so I can keep playing a
[ __ ] CEO make this worth it you get a
mug
hey stud muffin how you do wanna come
over here show big man a robot a good
time huh oh yeah big strong imperious
shoulders when I show me what a big
strong imperious you are yeah come over
here please seven centimeters into bed
join my club bit rattle with Carla
dot-com / markup
I'll show you good time
P P Q P P sccp and the very sexy PPK
what do they all have in common they're
all Walthers who are a wonderful sponsor
to this program we can't thank them
enough and listen there are a lot of
good firearms out there we know that you
have options I personally think that
well Thurs are the best that you can
purchase but at that point I think
Mercedes BMW Saab if this were 1993 I
don't know but the point is they also
have the balls to to sponsor this show
so our challenge to you is if you're
looking to purchase a firearm just try
the Walther that's it go to your local
range ask about it try all the different
firearms and let us know what you think
try them all
[Music]
[Music]
that's called the Eric and John snow
thought this will be cool I'll jump in
the lake with my cape and then he
waterboarded himself
I wasn't shackled I was driving him
unbeknownst to him why I should say
beforehand after he was waterboard
himself was very beknownst oh yeah it
was beknownst he knew hodgetwins twin
calm Minds coming up here pretty soon
still not sold on the game of thrones
review and thanks so much together
McGinnis i don't know a ton of stuff
miss weeks of effort we put in for you
guys so the headphone Presta uh one of
these hairs into my ear and it was like
a metal wire hmm like a wire coat hanger
I put it there going in alright so this
is one of the closing segment which is
the reason some of you are here and the
reason some of you tune out alright
that's fair either I still appreciate
both both of you being here so with
YouTube's new algorithms who knows how
long you will be here I'm gonna offer
some advice here which may seem more
reckless than usual I know that's before
I say it some of you will hear it and
say stupid isn't this fly in the face of
everything else you've told us as far as
being disciplined working smart all of
that no let me explain something here
the fundamentals never change okay so if
ever I layer something new on top of
what we've discussed know the
fundamentals discipline honesty goals
measurable progress consistency all of
those things are most important ok like
I said I've said this before working
smarter not necessarily harder
always leaving the hard option on the
table though always leaving that hard
door open but any advice that someone
gives you can't help you unless you're
doing the fundamentals ok the day to day
when no one is looking stays the same
ok we're talking about extraneous
circumstances here we often talk about
becoming the kind of man woman person Z
you want to be but let me start with
something else here let me start with
the kind of man because I'm a man we'll
just continue with man I know the woman
watching let me start with the kind of
man you don't want to be don't be the
man where something comes up not only is
that the kind of man you don't want to
be it's the kind of man no one else
wants you to be what do I mean by that
something comes up okay let me ask you
how many of us know this person could be
a family member could be a friend could
be an employer
someone you work with I don't know
someone whom you're relying on for
something doesn't matter what it is and
ah man something something came up
they're always late they don't come
through on their promises they hand in
their work late plans get canceled
you have that person in your head take a
second okay now let me ask you you
admire that person you respect that
person don't be that person
and I say this because I know that
you're probably thinking of someone
who's real deadbeat maybe a complete
dirtbag but guess what you do it too
I do we all do the only difference
between you and this person you're
thinking of right now is that the
something came up guy did it one too
many times and it became a way of life
now we often talk about making excuses
we hear that a lot but here's the thing
think of anything you need to accomplish
or that you seek to accomplish right now
you don't need to make an excuse to not
do it there's almost always a valid
reason for it not to be completed that's
why I hate the term making excuses how
often have you told someone that they're
making excuses and they come back with
will it's true and guess what they're
right there actually was traffic the
printer did run out of ink they actually
did get caught up on a work call they
couldn't get out of people don't make
excuses people take and out and that's
why they get so indignant when you tell
them that they're making excuses because
in their mind they justify it and in
reality they're not technically wrong
but you're upset because of your
expectations of them my point is this
the only difference between you and that
person is how many times you've done it
and you know what if you keep that in
check and you stay in line with all the
fundamentals we've talked about
sometimes you do have to throw this is
why since this advice might seem
reckless sometimes you do have to throw
caution to the wind and be the guy who
just bulldozes the some things that come
up there's always going to be something
that comes up and another and another
and another until you find yourself
boxed in I want to see more people just
bulldoze in them pick an obstacle really
this is a challenge right pick an
obstacle that's been holding you back
pick a fear pick something that's come
up right now go blow past it I don't
know so if you're saying that's not that
simple you know what
sometimes it is think of when you were a
kid I remember I used to get into the
lake or the pool in Canada was really
called first tip of the season and I can
remember dipping my toe in working
myself up pacing back and forth and I
remember with my brother and we'd say 1
2 3 go
and neither one of us jumped in we'd do
it maybe 15 times 3 go until finally one
of us jumped in on three but what was
the difference what changed between the
first 14 times and the 15th nothing but
my resolve
it was the same problem it was the same
barrier to entry the water hadn't gotten
any warmer I just decided that I was
going to jump now take that and apply it
to a situation of actual consequence in
life how much wasted time could that be
because something came up
how many count two threes before you
jump in could be years and the only
thing that's going to change for you to
accomplish what you need to do is your
result just bulldoze the obstacle fix
your result bite down on the mouth guard
tuck your chin swine and yet listen I
get it some of you are going to have a
harder time doing this so another you
might be a more difficult point in your
life a lot of it depends on how long
you've been letting this go on who cares
right now bulldoze the obstacle brush
off to something came up don't be that
guy and I say guy because I'm a man you
know what women don't want a man who
when the rubber meets the road something
came up
employees don't want a boss who when it
comes time for paychecks something came
up
his bosses don't want employees who when
things are something came up the world
the life you want for yourself does not
reward the man or the person who when it
comes to fulfilling your purpose
something came up so the challenge this
week is really simple what do you want
for your life think specifically if
that's something that's come up all
right think of what you want think of
something that stopped you from
accomplishing got it take a second pause
it if you need to
now bulldozer period don't be that
something came up guy the world doesn't
need anymore
see you next week
[Music]